in part one of this series we learned
about Alaska Natives fight to keep their
land in part two we'll go to a village
that's been fighting to protect one of
the last pristine wildlife habitats in
the u.s. you look at the beauty of this
land here right here there's not too
many places left in the world like this
Alaska Natives are hit first and hit
hardest by global climate change every
single major oil company has a stake
there we have an obligation to protect
that place and again it's not just for
us it's for everyone we're a family we
all take care of each other
all the ground must take care of you
when you're growing up here Arctic
village is home to about 150 Alaskan
Natives who are part of the Gwich'in
nation the village sits on the southern
edge of the Arctic National Wildlife
Refuge also known as Anwar the fight to
keep oil drilling off the coastal plain
of the refuge has been in and out of
Congress since the 1970s you're going to
have to let us find additional reserves
of oil to preserve the national security
interests of this country the oil
company tried to say that development
would not hurt the caribou but they are
not telling the truth in 2015 President
Obama tried to protect the refuge from
drilling but with President Trump in
office and a huge budget crisis in
Alaska drilling is now back on the table
the economic benefits will be
substantial and the environmental
impacts will be minimal but many
disagree getting that oil could threaten
the survival of both polar bears in
caribou which give birth on the northern
coastal plain a spill like Exxon Valdez
which killed hundreds of thousands of
animals on Alaska south coast would be
devastating here for us caribou it is 80
percent of which a person's diet it is
essential to our culture and our
spirituality so whatever happens to the
porcupine Care will hurt happens to the
Witch and
all the food and supplies that they
can't get from the land including
gasoline must be flown in from Fairbanks
two hours away by bush plane which is
why gas here cost $10 a gallon everybody
19:20 so 19 dollars for this $13 we
can't afford to buy our all our food our
food comes from the land this is just
extra we in the resource state live in
third world conditions Alaska has seen
billions of dollars of profits since the
discovery of the largest oil field in
North America at Prudhoe Bay but dozens
of Alaska Native villages have never
been equipped with basic resources like
running water
when's that benefit is going to be the
come poll companies any economic benefit
for Alaska Native villages will be a
drop in the bucket
[Music]
most Alaska Native villages still live
our ancestral way of life we still hunt
we still fish we still gather there's
old old ancestral ways that have been
passed down generation to generation
that we still follow
that's our subsistence way of life this
time of year it's getting cold out so
what I do here is I cut slices of meat
and all that and I'll hang it here and
I'll build a fire so it can get smoked
flavor into it when you feel that it's
there's enough smoke flavor and all that
we bring it inside and we slice them
into pieces and all that we'll hang it
on the rack
I've been skimming and cutting up care
about 45 years now I've been doing this
basically all my life when I'm handling
processing the strip show that king
salmon or I am butchering Didache the
moose or if it's I write caribou it is a
feeling of engaging with my entire being
this is the way we live this is this is
the way we live this is the way it's
always been for me
to me our way of life is more valuable
than any economic benefit economic
benefit is short-term it's here today
gone tomorrow our way of life will
sustain us forever and this land will
sustain us forever
it said the refuge could hold between 6
and 16 billion barrels of oil but nobody
knows for sure the Trump administration
has been pushing for seismic tests to
find out but environmentalists say that
even the testing could harm wildlife
shot 3 in the middle of my summer up
there they stopped there but I mean they
went over we don't rely on roads we
don't know why on stores we rely on our
land so that's where us hunters come in
just a thought of losing it would hurt
you know it would hurt bad
if we didn't have caribou stomachs will
be empty freezers would be empty and
there'll be a lot of struggle and I'm
not gonna go down without a fight
Arctic village is just one of many
Native villages threatened by the oil
industry in Alaska others are eroding
because of climate change are struggling
to survive despite oil-company succumb
because they're gonna need this they're
gonna want this beautiful piece of
country that we have people really need
to pay attention to what's at stake here
and it's not just an issue that should
be relevant to us as indigenous people
as which in people but all Americans it
is public lands you have a say in what
happens there
as a kitchen woman there's a lot at
stake for my people and for the world in
this next video you'll meet a young
Alaska Native woman who is revitalizing
the traditional practices of chin
tattooing